bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono poi j
oggi siamo su get mario 3 scoperto che
se siete nei menu principale e premete
il tasto 4 non funziona porca [ __ ]
ok ha funzionato meno male sto facendo
una figura di merda di cazzo siamo ok
non era così però va bene il partito
qualcosa che non so che cos'è
vabbè reggimento e save the seas o buon
action che non riuscirò mai a
pronunciarle premete il tasto 4 dovrebbe
aprirvi una mappa nuova che non è questa
ma comunque va bene anche questo dato
che è sempre che mario purtroppo va bene
inizia allora è una mappa nuova che
hanno mai fatto e siamo già morti non ho
fatto neanche un cazzo di salto decente
alla ragazzi nel frattempo che vado
avanti vi spiego perché niente il fumo
nel frattempo che vado avanti perché io
penso di andare avanti o io pretendo di
andare avanti certo poi magari non
scappare un cazzo mi più di un salto
devo fare un saluto potevo farlo salto a
lezione al ahram innanzitutto
ringraziarvi perché siete stati in
tantissimi a consigliarvi get mario 3
perché ho fatto un sondaggio permesso
fatti dei giochi messo lucius ho messo
anche mario
e ha tanta altra roba molto divertente
voi che cosa avete scelto
avrete di certo tutti che sommario 3
grazie ragazzi veramente mi chiamo vi
amo tantissimo allora aspettate un
attimo perché craxi come dovrei farlo
spiegatemelo porca [ __ ] non c'è verso
porca avuto in tutti i modi lo sto
provando e dai qualche altro gol che
forse ce l'ho fatta se maledizione è
giovata porca [ __ ] ce l'ho fatta
adesso l'affare non lo prendo bene
grande allora ragazzi vi spiego un po un
attimo come mai ho abbandonato che di
mario 2 e che è praticamente cat mario
due praticamente non era come il primo
che di mario sem brava ma non era come
più che mario perché era incentrato al
cento per cento sulle trappole c'è nel
senso prati mentre tu giocavi hackett
mario 2 ed era un prima e di un gioco
fatto sulle trappole non potevi fare più
di un passo che cadeva in una trappola
prima mente è qua stiamo andando avanti
all'infinito che cazzola che c'è un
obiettivo da cosa no che cazzo sta
succedendo perfetto ragazzi stavano
andando avanti con idiota ed era finito
lì allora proviamo vedere se ce n'è un
altro premuto 5 stavo ok
questo è un altro ancora e coi conti
cazzo ce ne sono e allora sono mini
livelli cioè non lo so perché voi mi
avete detto che era più che era un altro
che mario però non è che
il bello che le cose le so anche io lo
sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo già ci sono
andato lo stesso perché non è il mio
cervello sia arrendo marco zocco di
merda si è arreso proprio perché non ha
senso avere comunque penso che consiste
nel fare tanti mini livelli comunque era
già penso che consiste nel fare tanto
vabbè rai ha dunque penso che consiste
nel fare tantissimi mini livelli allora
carmi un attimo dovevo provare a dalla
spettata in seconda ok ok la prima la
prima non cade perfetto la seconda la
seconda neanche la terza mi pare di no
ma [ __ ]
sì se ce l'ho fatta
va beh scusate lo fuori a mare
sono contento c'è il fantasma di merda
qualche incazzo successo mi ha sparato
in orbita ma che cazzo è sì certo ma
prima che riescono di nuovo
l'intuizione non vi viene cioè forse
perché mi incazzavo troppo forse perché
in casa ma purtroppo diamo che cazzo mi
esce fuori stavolta ma cos'è
siamo partiti di merda maledizione cosa
mi devo uscire la sto di vello
sono vivo ok ragazzi siamo non so come
sono uscito
allora questa è una parte che mi ricordo
che era in cat mario uno però non devo
allora qua sotto se era uguale cosa è
cambiato dal gioco originale niente la
ricordo ho dei ragazzi ci siamo allora
devo saltare non mi ricordo se devo
saltare da sopra una foto non ricordo mi
pare da io mi ricordo mai così ancora ok
ragazzi siamo mi sono ricordato che cela
strafare perfetto allora raga dobbiamo
centrare quel [ __ ] fantasma di merda
devo riuscirci
allora aspettate che passi che non è
caduto nel book già un traguardo non mi
ricordo quando ti dottoressa fa adesso
così accanto di merda perché c'è una
mila di merda john maison ora ad
arrivare legion mezzolara ce la posso
fare
ce la posso fare bye bye bye bye bye bye
si no
[Musica]
oh mio dio non ci posso credere è stata
una cosa imposti sia adesso c'è quella
enorme adesso mi ammazzo no invece non
mi ricordava come si faceva va bene ce
la posso fare ad arrivare alla fine ci
sarà qualcosa di nuovo per forza perché
non può essere uguale sono che cazzo che
ho fatto a fare
ok mai così grande adesso devo saltare
su quella fare ma deve andare a cui che
è cool assurda non ci posso gallarate
una ragazza dalla destra devo andare di
qua e non mi ricordo se non sfondare il
muro andare lì sopra per fermare il
soffitto singolo va bene e prevede
ragazzo rifacendo che mario dove noi
velo per mario è meno fermare lo aveva
fermato a cat mario 2 l'ultimo episodio
permette sta rifacendo quello vai ti
prego fa che da gol di che culo non ci
credo e non mi ricordo che cosa devo
farmi ricordo di pratiche funzioni
qualsiasi cosa siano mi ricordo dove
tipo saltare pertanto sbagli no ok ok
non è successo niente
come è successo niente se non dovevo far
nulla per una volta che non c'era la
trappola mischia carta addosso va bene
va bene allora ragazzi mi hanno fermato
qui in cat mario due c'era questo punto
davvero fermato è quindi a questo punto
linea di continuare io non so nulla di
qua da qui in poi non so proprio niente
ea ma posso nuotare che figo che figata
so che è perfetto la possono darci uno
squalo vero fermato qui non non pensavo
si potesse andare più ok perfetto sono
morto fantastico l'importante è che
riesca a farcela gabbiano fermato un
click mario due perché era è diventato
associa io ovviamente stiamo continuando
con io l'ho voluto fermare cat mario
perché era diventata una cosa
impossibile pieno di trappole
ovviamente stiamo continuando quella
cosa lì alla fine devo sclerare uguale
non è che cambia nulla perché pensa io
spero fosse diverso socket mario invece
uguale cazzo
e solo il continuo cos'è quello una
medusa lo saltarla se c'è grande [ __ ]
creduta di merda ce l'ho fatta e allora
è un po un casino raga perché devo
riuscire a far cadere
ok cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo perfetto
adoratori cina è stato fermo no non ci
credo e cura perfetta la stiamo facendo
il possibile ragazzi impossibile c'è la
bandiera c'è un mandela mi servono
affanculo gli squali di merda ce la
posso fare la bandiera da chiara
raggiungo dai ne ho fatti passare gli
squali dai dai dai dai dai dai set
che culo
bene allora poi è pieno di squali porca
[ __ ] come faccio a schivarli tu dove 31
nel tubo entrate c'era un motivo solo ho
smesso di giocare a sta merda ma dài e
dài dài deve da rivedere devo saltare
non saltare sulle cadeau weil amica mi
stanno dito in cancrena maizza dove
cazzo sono finito [ __ ] by non sar
domani sono già faccio
sto passando sotto che perfetto ma
insomma poi mio zio santissimo che cosa
brutta dove cazzo si esce
c'è un punto di uscita il suo posto di
merda no allora la lega è una cosa
impossibile giorno mi sta uccidendo
ragazzi non fatelo mai ragazzi non si
possa risalire dove cazzo sale dove sono
non solo perché no [ __ ] tua gli
squali
cosa cazzo ho fatto ho sbagliato
cliccare maledizione sogliano piano
piano si fermi fermi fermi che è
difficile la situazione piceno si è
fatta ce l'ho fatta calmi adesso ce l'ha
fatta stiamo tutti tranquilli
devo riuscire a passarmi fai passare in
qualche modo no non c'è verso cazzo ci
sono gli squali merda
devo devo suscita pasti niente di più
porca [ __ ] come faccio a cheese c'è
un solo buco dove passa allora penso sia
l'ultimo giusto perché vuole farmi fare
il giro
mai infatti non è quello malizia è
questo qua ce l'ho fatta
ok allora adesso non so bene la
situazione
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
[Musica]
sono vivo ancora come cazzo faccio
servivo muori stronzo muori perché tanto
se in deficiente di merda stai tu stai
su maledizione ok c'è la dovrei aver
fatto stavolta devo andare avanti
ragazzi è un passo e vedete che stop
perché ho smesso di fare sto gioco
perché questo gioco perché non facciamo
in tempo a finire la frase ed ecco la
spiegazione perché pieno di trappole del
cazzo che devo riniziare tutto daccapo
porca [ __ ] e non me ne frega un cazzo
sto dicendo un cazzo di parolacce ogni 4
secondi cazzo perché è impossibile o
star di nove dove lo so che non devo
salire di grado salieri qua in effetti
allora forse non devo andare avanti di
qua finché stiamo calmi vabbè ok che
cazzo è dove sono dove sono dove sono
finito a e tipo grandissimo ce l'ho
fatta c'è la stoffa manca ragazzi ma il
tubo ci siamo ci siamo non ci posso che
l'amica mi viene quasi da tremare porca
troche dove sto andando o chiara che
tutti calmissimi tutti i cani lo come
fatto essere così deficiente per ci sono
ragazzi dio mio zio
se non ci posso credere
mio dio che era password a sto livello
era stata una cosa impressionante
devo preoccuparmi devo scendere come
prima vero devo scendere come prima
tranquillo
[Musica]
se ce l'ho fatta
siamo arrivati a marano questo è il
posto è il posto di prima ma per il mite
e non è che mario cioè prima intenso no
cliccando quel tasto li fai livelli
sparsi in poche parole non lo sapevo va
bene tanto sto punto quale aveva già
fatto eravamo arrivati che dovevi
correre all'infinito e non so come
continuare quindi ragazze e che per
questo episodio la posso chiudere qui
sei riuscito a capire come minchia si fa
questo punto maledetto
datemi una mano vabbè io per questo
episodio la chiudo qui sei video è
piaciuto lasciato commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video troppe nella descrizione se
la siete a fare syfy scrivetemi noi ci
vediamo al prossimo viso bella ragazzi